я цілуюся ти цілуєшся він вона воно
цілується
ми
цілюємось ви цілюєтеся вони цілюють
у таких невеликих групах щоб можна було
присвятити більшу уваги кожному німців
вчать українську після вторгнення РФ до
України та хвилі біженців від війни
чимало німців збагнули різницю між
українською та російською і навіть стали
і записуватися на курси української
мова то
мова а не діалект Я люблю українську
мову
генріху флінґу 62 попри поважний вік він
старано робить Усі вправи на екзамен
до екзамену
[музика]
у молодості Генріх вивчав
слов'янознавство
словістика в першу чергу означає
російську мову
і ми не сприймали українську як окрему
культуру та мову в той час
тож було не цікаво вчити українську
Нині ж мова йде саме про те що
український доводиться захищати себе як
культуру та мову і ми розуміємо що було
дещо неправильно повністю ігнорувати це
та зосереджуватися на російській мові
вчителька Оксана чобанян у березні
Минулого року разом з донькою була
змушена виїхати з рідного Харкова а саме
салтівки яку тоді нещадно обстрілювали
російські війська Раніше вона навчала
дітей у Харкові німецької А тепер німці
в окельні Української є люди які
цікавляться мовою і
люди які допомагають українцям і хочуть
спілкуватися з українцями української
мови а не російською бо вони
вважають що Вивчаючи мову вони
підтримують нас І дійсно дають
такий поштовх щоб люди які спілкувалися
раніше навіть в Харкові російською мовою
почали спілкуватися рідними
що що що війна
не буде
закінчивати що війна незабаром
закінчився або буде краще закінчиться
такої забаром незабаром
не закінчився
і закінчиться
лише тут у фолькс Хох шульєв народному
університеті в Кельні є чотири курси
української Два учні та два онлайн з
квітня минулого року їх вже відвідали
або ще вчаться понад 100 людей у
невеликих групах з різним рівнем
української
тому що вони звикли всі інші мови які
вони можливо знають Вони всі на базі
латині а тут у нас кирилиця і багато
різних букв які в принципі їм знайомі
але вони читаються по-різному в принципі
цей шок ми як українці Ми пробуємо саме
першого класу з вивчення англійської
мови щось схоже для дорослих людей Це
звісно трохи важче одне з ваших слів
звісно який вже слово яке стало мимом це
слово паляниця через поєднання букв і ця
ці букви їм неймовірно важко вимовляти
також звісно ці слова як наприклад
полуниця те ж саме є вам із Отто родом з
Польщі але вже майже 40 років живе у
Німеччині коли з'явилися можливість
відвідувати курси української залюбки
записалися бо я дуже люблю Україну і я з
Польщі і моя
хрещена
була з Львова
і
я хочу помогати українцям
можна
протягом останніх кількох місяців я
працювала як волонтерка з українськими
сім'ями у держстановах А зараз у
гімназії Куди ходить Моя дочка щоб
просто швидше контактувати з людьми щоб
мати можливість краще подбати про них
тому і вивчаємо мову
Ліза херус має українське коріння її
батько з Одеси вдома трохи говорили
російською Але після 24 лютого Все
змінилося для неї тепер принципово
говорити саме українською порівняно з
німецькою українська граматика важче
вважає Ліза
в українській сім відмінків
велонімецький 4 тобто в українській на
три більше в українській багато винятків
Я думаю що це також дуже складно що
недостатньо просто вивчити правила а є
ще багато винятків
вчителька Оксана каже що коли вчила
дітей думали що німецька складна але
виявилося що українська ще складніша
зокрема граматика та наголоси з цим
найбільше помилок вам новий
сам подобається
вам подобається новий
дерев'яний стіл він дуже гарний
трапляються і кумедні випадки з
сучасними гаджетами влітку
це було три рази на тиждень ми працювали
по 5-6 годин і коли
учень чи там слово сірий його iPhone
спрацював тому що я спрацювала сірі
він повторював сірий сіра сірі і сірі
почала реагувати на його голос це було
смішно
Оксана задоволена тим як її учні та
учениці читають і розмовляють Минулого
року вони ще зовсім цього не вміли каже
коли бачить що в них все виходить це не
може не тішити
[музика]
у його немає свого зеленого светра У
нього у нього немає Немає свого сининого
цвета
у народному університеті в Кельні як і в
усій землі північний рейвестфалія попит
на українську мову тримається це
найбільш густонаселена земля Німеччини
яка прийняла найбільшу кількість
українців понад 20-7 тисяч
нове ну і звісно Україна надходить зі
шпальт газет та з телевізійних каналів
через це також принципи актуальна тема
на жаль мені дуже шкода що це саме вона
актуальна через війну
якщо мені якщо ми будемо запитали я б
краще не викладала українську мову
іноземцям Головне щоб він не було Тому
що мотив через який я її викладається
звісно те що ця наша країна актуальна
але причина
як краще не відповідала
Єва впевнено і без помилок пише в ці
слова українською коли закінчиться війна
Усі вони хочуть відвідати Україну
зокрема Львів а поки Урок закінчено
[музика]